TERRENCE RYAN: This is going
to be navigating Google Cloud
Platform.
If this is not the session
you're supposed to be in,
you've waited a long
time for nothing.
Let me give a quick intro.
I am going to reveal little
bits and pieces of information
about me over the
course of this talk,
but I want to know
who you guys are.
So how many people in this
room spend most of their time
at work developing?
How many spend
most of their time
working on systems
being a sysadmin?
How many do both?
Because you love DevOps?
Your company won't
hire more people.
OK.
How many people tell developers
or systems people what to do?
Oh, shoot.
All right.
I've got to cut a lot
of jokes, which is fine.
I've got to cut a
lot of manager jokes.
It's fine, because we're
running short on time.
So my goal with this
session is specifically
to help developers and
CIS admins to figure out--
if you're new to
GCP, to figure out
how to find the solutions
to your problems.
I am not going to talk about
us relative to the competition
too much.
There's just too much to do.
So I'm going to take
the baseline assumption
that you're already on board.
I understand that
may not be the case,
but it's a pleasant fiction that
we'll just all share together,
and we'll be fine.
My other goal is to not show off
our org chart too much, which
is difficult, because
most of our leadership
are, in fact, blue hexagons with
weird figures on their faces.
Luckily, they've
lucked into a job
here where they can be that.
We have a lot of products.
We have a lot, a lot of things.
And they all have names.
And those names may or may not
be descriptive of what they do,
'cause reasons.
So my goal is to get you from
looking at this big chart
and feeling like this to
being able to find what
it is that you want to use.
Also, some of this is more
complex than other parts of it.
What computing you use--
what is going on?
There we go.
Whoever is messing
with it, stop.
So some of this is more
complex than other things.
So I am going to start
talking about computing.
I'm an application
developer by trade,
and so I'm going to
spend a lot of time
talking about processing
and doing things.
Then I'm going to go
into networking storage.
I will talk a little
bit about big data.
But I will warn you that as
an application developer,
I don't do a lot of big data.
So you're going to get C+
answers if you probe me,
which we may not have time
for, which is kind of good.
I should have admitted that.
Also, we're going to talk about
administration and development.
And then finally, because
we have to do it by law--
we're at a Google
conference-- we
should talk about
machine learning.
So I'm going to focus on
computing and storage,
because there are
difficult questions
to answer in those two spaces,
like which thing should I
use for this.
Whereas with networking
administration development,
it's a lot of let me
find the right tool
for this particular thing.
Let me just-- what's its name?
And then finally,
machine learning-- you're
going to hear a
lot about machine
learning at this conference.
So I feel like I can kind
of give a very, very--
I don't have to go too
deep with machine learning.
With any of these icons we
had up, each one of these
could be an hour-long talk, or
more, or a whole conference,
depending on what
we're talking about.
So with that, I'm going to get
into computing or doing things.
So when you talk
about computing,
you're usually talking about one
of three things in this space.
You're talking about
virtual machines.
So I have stuff that
runs somewhere else.
I would like it to run here.
How do I get it to run here?
We have containers,
since everything
is moving to containers,
as we were completely
told constantly, constantly
by the zeitgeist.
And then finally, serverless.
Serverless is for we
don't want to deal
with the underlying
infrastructure.
We just want to write code
and push it somewhere.
Now those of you that
have been following
this space for a
while, you may know
that we talked a lot about
platform as a service
a couple of years ago.
And the dirty secret that
no one's going to tell you
is that serverless is
platform as a service,
but for people who have
fallen into the Gartner
trough of disillusionment.
So we've got to
call it serverless
so you're not afraid of it.
But serverless is
another path, and we'll
talk about our solutions there.
So let us start with
the virtual machines.
They're pretty straightforward.
They are virtual machines.
You can choose one
from 64 processors.
You can go all the way to 0.6
gigs of RAM all the way up
to 416.
And basically, you're bound by
how many processors you use.
You have to use a minimum
of 0.9 to a maximum
of 6.5 gigs per processor.
Those of you that are
looking at the slides
carefully and doing math,
that doesn't add up.
We have one or two
configurations that
have less than 0.9 gigs of RAM.
You add disks to it.
You can add simple
persistent storage.
You can add SSDs.
You can add RAM disks.
You can also--
I don't know if we announced
that yet, so I won't add that.
We also have-- you can build off
of our preconfigured images, so
Debian, Ubuntu, Red Hat, other
flavors of Linux and Windows.
You can customize those
images and save them,
or you can even upload
your own images.
And we like to say that our
VMs spin up in tens of seconds.
What do we mean by that?
We mean that when you're
in your hotel room testing
the night before, they
spin up in 20 seconds.
When you're in front of a crowd
of people, they spin up in 40.
I don't know how they know.
I think it would be
in their best interest
to spin up quickly
in front of guests,
but they do what they do.
And you'll see that in a minute.
Now, I just want a blank VM.
I want to build it myself.
That's fine.
You get that.
But a lot of times,
people want to fool around
with something
already built, like I
want a WordPress install.
I want a MongoDB
setup already for me.
So we have a tool that can do
that called Cloud Launcher.
We have images
that are available.
So for many and most
common software packages,
you're just going to be able
to go there and load them up.
Now, we don't
manage them for you
after you've run them
in Cloud Launcher.
It's as if basically
you spun up a VM,
did all the configuration work,
and you're at the same spot.
So it's just a jumpstart.
So I'm going to quickly show
a demo of Compute Engine,
because demos are fun.
So this is Compute Engine.
This is the interface for it.
I'm going to go ahead
and create an instance
and show you some
of the options here.
So I'm going to customize this.
I'm going to build it with
as many cores as I want,
a little less memory.
And this is great.
We have pre-built steps.
If you go back to
the basic view,
you can set very
particular things.
But let's say you need somewhere
between 8 and 16 cores.
You can dial that in
very specifically.
So I'll go to 12.
There we go.
I can choose my image,
I can do all that.
I'm going to go and create.
Now, we'll see if
it creates in time.
But I'm going to use the image
I Julia Child last night.
Yes, I use Julia
Child as a verb.
And you'll see that I
didn't pull down any certs.
I didn't fire up
my own terminal.
I just went to the browser,
and I am browsing directly in.
Now, which one is
going to come up first?
SSH?
Oh, the instance popped
green, so it was ready.
We weren't watching it
fully, so it was like, OK,
maybe I'll spin up fast.
And there we are.
And now we're on our
command line SSH.
I can do whatever
I want on this VM--
that quick, that easy.
All right.
Thank you.
Yeah, I love SSH as a browser.
It is life changing
when you get it.
So now we're going to
move on to containers.
How many people here are fooling
around with containers already?
OK.
How many are running
them in production?
How many have said
the word "docker"
in a parking lot, and
a conference sprung up
around you?
It happens.
So good.
So containers is another
path for virtualization--
is an alternative
to virtualization.
Instead of carving
off a whole machine
and using all of the
resources dedicated to the VM,
you basically fool
all your hosts--
sorry, all your containers
into thinking they're
the only machine running.
And so you can split up
processes and start things up
really, really quickly
for those that aren't
as full on on containers yet.
That was a very quick
explanation for containers.
So containers at Google--
first thing we talk about
is Container Engine,
which is Managed
Kubernetes, which
leaves the obvious
question, kuber-what-es?
Kubernetes is a container
orchestration system,
meaning if you want
to just spin up
one container, dockers, great.
If you want to spin up
gigantic sets of interconnected
containers that need
complex networking that
goes between them to
allocate resources
and services between them,
it gets complicated and big.
So here's a three-tier app.
I want to spin up a single
instance of a database
that we would call a--
what would we call it?
I would call it a pet set, but
we call it something else now.
But it's a pet.
You just want one.
And then I've got the API layer,
which is multiple versions,
multiple processes
running for the API layer,
and a front layer.
All of these are wired together.
If one of them goes
down, it will--
because they said I want
four of the middle layer,
it's going to make sure that
there are always four running.
So if one goes down,
it'll resurrect.
And this allows you to
organize your containers
into what we call workloads.
Now, a workload could
be a microservice,
which is a lot of what
containers have been known for.
But it could also be things like
scheduled jobs or batch jobs,
anything where you need
to spin up large amounts
or small amounts of the same
process over and over again.
Containers and Kubernetes could
be a good solution for you.
Now, this is running
on top of Kubernetes.
But from a systems
perspective, here's
what you have to do
to run Kubernetes.
You have to build
up your machine.
You have to pick
the OS, pick where
you're going to run it on prem,
another cloud provider, or us.
We would love to
have your business.
And then you have to
install Kubernetes on them.
And then once you
install Kubernetes,
you have to set up a network.
You have to make sure that
network has DNS, which
helps with service discovery.
You then set up
logging and monitoring,
because those
things are the sorts
of things we like to
know about our servers,
that stuff is happening.
Maybe you're not
cool with the fact
that they resurrect and go away,
the containers, so you want
to add some persistent storage.
And now that you have your
Kubernetes cluster up,
you have to make
sure you maintain
the version of
Kubernetes and the OS,
and make sure you patch the OS,
and handle all those updates
and all of that maintenance.
Or there's this little box
called Container Engine.
And there's like a
little box right there
that says Create a
Container Cluster for me.
And that's all you have to do.
All of that thing, all
of that explanation
I did-- or you just
press that button.
So we like to say
that-- oh, I was
going to do a quick demo
of Container Engine.
See?
I have terminal up and ready.
All right.
So I'm going to run one command.
I'm going to show
you this visualizer.
So this visualizer
is right now looking
at the containers that are
running on my Kubernetes
cluster.
I'm going to run a make
command to get deploy.
And we should see--
assuming the network gods
have been-- there we go.
The network gods
have been appeased.
And so I am building multiple
systems at the same time.
I am building four
database servers
that power seven front
ends, two copies of Drupal,
one copy of a custom app, a
Node.js app, WordPress, and one
other Zen developer server.
So I just spun all of this up.
All these machines got their
networking, their back end,
and all spun from nothing.
And now the dark green ones
are going to get IP addresses.
I don't think I have enough
time to dig into them.
But it's important to note
that those are public,
and the light green
ones-- the SQL servers--
we would like them
to not be public.
And we can do that.
So in a very quick
way-- one of my apps
is up, so I'm just going to
click, see if it's working.
No.
All right.
Ditch.
Don't have enough time.
I think something is weird
in the browser there.
OK.
So that puts us here.
So that's just a
quick launching up
a whole bunch of different
workloads on Kubernetes.
I can do it fast.
I can do it scripted.
Kubernetes is what
we call-- sorry.
Container Engine is managed
Kubernetes or containers
as a service.
We have smart default set
for monitoring and logging,
DNS and service discovery.
And we can also auto scale.
So you can set up your
Kubernetes cluster on GKE
to basically-- as
your load goes up,
spin up more hardware resources
in order to handle it,
or spin down, as
the case may be.
And so that's container engine.
Now, another way we have
of dealing with containers
is something called app
engine flexible environment.
Now, App Engine-- when
we talk about app engine,
we talk about it usually
in terms of serverless.
Because it's a
platform as a service.
You don't ever
really interact with
the underlying infrastructure.
But under the covers,
App Engine flexible--
on App Engine standard,
but App Engine flexible
is running Docker.
So you can flip a bit and
say runtime equals custom.
And then you can put whatever
docker file you want,
and we will run it
as an App Engine app.
Now, what that buys
you is connecting
to a lot of our resources.
And you get auto scaling
out of the box from 1
to however big you need to grow.
And then you get one
endpoint for service.
So a lot of the work of setting
up a service kind of goes out.
You don't have to do it.
So that is App Engine
flexible environment.
There are two helpers to
help you deal with containers
in Google Cloud platform.
We have Container Registry
and Container Builder.
Container Registry is a storage
repository for Docker images.
So you build your images, you
push them up to the registry,
and then they're
behind our security,
so you can lock them down with
your Google Cloud account.
And you can pull them from
Container Engine or App Engine
Flexible or a Docker client
running on your own machine.
And in fact, what I
usually do is I push stuff
up the container registry.
I will be in production
on Kubernetes.
But in development, I
will develop on Docker.
So I can use the same image in
the same builds in both places.
Container Builder is brand
new, as in Monday it came out.
It is a service-- if
you're doing a lot of work
on containers, you
reach a point where
you need to build
infrastructure to make sure
that your builds are
consistent and you're
going through whatever
continuous integration
tools you have.
Container Builder will
just do that for you.
And it can integrate
with other CI
systems and other repositories.
Or you will just
build it and store it
for you on Container
Registry and speed up
that whole process.
That's containers.
I'll move on to our
friends serverless.
Serverless-- we have our friend
app engineer flexible runtime.
Now, I, said it was a container
technology, and it is.
But if you don't
flip the switch,
you're going to use
one of our run times
instead of your own Docker file.
And the runtime under the
covers is a Docker file
that we built
specifically for this.
We have set languages
built already,
and we're working
on adding more.
But it's Java 8, Python 2, 7,
and 3.5, Node.js, Ruby, PHP,
and Go.
Version numbers are a
little muddled right now,
because I can't remember
if we've released the thing
or not.
So the big
differentiator here is
that under the covers,
like I said, it is Docker.
So you can add extra
things to our Docker file.
So you can add extra software,
add extra configuration,
and really open up the
capabilities of your machine--
I'm sorry-- your application.
As opposed to app
engine standard runtime,
which is much more locked down
in terms of what languages
you can use.
Python 2.7, Java 7, PHP 5.5, Go.
1.6 or 8-- can't
remember where it's at--
the abilities are
much more constrained.
For example, PHP you can extend
in C if you need to, normally.
But on App Engine Standard,
you can't do that.
You can do that on flex.
But on standard, you
can't add extra code.
You can add more PHP.
As long as your extensions
are in PHP, it'll work fine.
But once you try to dip
out of PHP, it won't work--
or Java, or Python, or Go.
Now, what do you get
for this constraint?
You get incredibly
rapid scaling.
And I'm going to show
that off in a second
to make it clear why the
scaling really is rapid
and why you might use it.
The other thing is it
scales down to zero.
Flex will scale
down to one instance
and have one instance responding
to requests all the time.
App Engine standard
will scale down to zero
and will not charge
you while it's at zero,
which is a nice feature.
Finally, we have cloud
functions, which we're really
excited to be talking about.
There are demos
out in the showcase
area that talk about this.
App Engine-- you're
abstracted to an app,
and you move an app
from place to place.
But the unit of abstraction
with functions is a function.
Why does that make sense?
Well, let's say I've got a
mobile app or some other thing,
and all the logic
is somewhere else.
And I just need to do one thing.
This is the halcyon,
perfect example of this.
I just want to send
mail from my mobile app.
You could write some code,
build an application,
set up routing so that your
API is easily called and locked
behind security, and everything
so that app can send a mail.
You could build an
application for it.
Or with cloud
functions, you just
write the one function
that sends the mail,
and it'll create
an endpoint for you
so you can attach to
your app, and so you
don't have to build an
entire application just
to serve up one function.
So that is the main
differentiator there.
And it is JavaScript,
Node.js only at the moment.
So I promised a demo of App
Engine in action taking load.
So here's my Kubernetes app.
It decided to load.
So I have here a set of 10
VMs, Compute Engine VMs.
And they're going
to hit that URL.
Please-- you can hit the URL.
Don't hit that URL.
No, no, don't.
Because you'll break the whole--
from cold, we're going to
see how App Engine scales.
So you can hit it after
I'm done with the demo
if that's your thing.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run one make command.
And I'll explain what I'm doing.
I'm instructing
each one of my VMs
to send 1,000 hits at that URL,
and to do it concurrently at 50
apiece, so a 500 QPS query.
So I'm going to run that.
I'm going to switch
back over here.
Someone hit the URL.
Someone did it.
That's all right.
You'll still see some magic.
So in a moment,
they're going to see
as soon as Compute
Engine gets the traffic
and starts sending it,
they start bouncing.
And that is App
Engine spinning up
instances of my
application in order
to handle the load
that's coming in.
And basically,
what will happen is
it can handle-- each
instance can handle
a certain amount of traffic
at once and then say,
hey, I'm a little peg.
And we'll start spinning up
more instance to take it.
That's how quickly we
spin up instances in order
to deal with your traffic.
And that's why the
whole scale to zero
is awesome, because it quickly
responds when you have traffic.
But then when we
don't have traffic,
it starts spinning down
instances, and three of you.
J'accuse three of you--
four.
All right.
Well, now I don't care.
Now you can just ping
it away all you want.
And you can see the
numbers go up in real time.
Yeah, you're really doing that.
You're really hitting the URL.
Oh, all right.
I've challenged people there.
They're feeling feisty.
So that's just a quick demo
of what App Engine can do.
And with that, we get to
the end of that section.
We are done all our
computing technology.
You should have a good idea
of where to do containers,
where to do serverless,
what the difference
between the serverless are, and
that our VMs are pretty quick.
So with that, I'm
going to change gears.
And this is going to be
more explaining things.
The networking is
incredibly complex,
but you can't really
get into it in this,
so I'm just going
to tell you where
to look for certain things.
So networking tends to be
about connections, security,
and availability.
People are looking
to connect us.
First thing is we have something
called the virtual network,
Cloud Virtual
Network, that allows
you to build your own private
networks for your project
and set up custom routes
to non-Google locations.
We also have this thing
called Cloud Interconnect,
which is kind of cool.
You directly peer to Google.
If you are doing a lot
of business with us
and you're transferring a lot
of data back from your network
to our network, it
may be something
that would be cost
effective for you.
Security from a
networking perspective--
two major ways we look at this--
VPN, which is gateway
to gateway only for us.
So this isn't for equipping
road warriors with a connection
to your network.
This is for connecting
two or more networks
via secure tunnel.
And you can use any
IPsec complaint gateway.
But the idea here is
you have machines at us,
machines on prem, machines
at Amazon or Azure
that you want to
connect together.
You can use this to do it.
Firewall-- it's a firewall.
You set up rules.
It's nothing too crazy.
But the reason why
I bring it here
is because this is about
discovering things.
When I first started
using Compute Engine,
one of the problems I
had was figuring out how
the hell do I open up a port.
I just want to open up some
random port, as one does.
And you have to basically
go through networking
to find the firewall settings to
create firewall rules that you
can then apply in
Compute Engine.
But it is maybe less than
intuitive the first time
you come to it, so I wanted
to make sure to call it out.
Look in the Networking
section of our app--
of our console is
what we call it--
to find these things.
At some point, someone
says, well, I want something
that you don't have.
What can I do?
Well, you can, in
Compute Engine,
build anything you want by hand.
And we actually have,
in Cloud Launcher,
VM setups for Baracuda, Brocade,
CloudFlare, and a whole bunch
of others.
I clearly went
alphabetical in my list.
And you can build these,
and you can manage them.
We don't manage these for you,
but you absolutely can do that.
Now, talking about
availability--
we have cloud CDN,
which you activate--
the interface for it is actually
through our load balancers,
which I'll talk
about in a Second.
And it basically uses
HTTP headers in order
to determine cacheability.
You can do ed caching, and
invalidation, and pre-loading,
and all sorts of things
you do with content.
If you want to do
more complex things,
this is not the
solution for you.
This is not meant to be
a comprehensive solution.
People want this as part
of a basic cloud package.
We offer it.
If you need more
complex things, we
have partners that are
more than happy to talk
to you about doing more
complex things with caching
with us and them.
So next is DNS.
This is interesting in that
it is the only thing I've ever
seen where we've promise 100%--
at Google that we've
promised 100% availability.
Our SLA is 100% availability.
And I had to double--
they didn't round up somewhere?
No.
It's 100% availability
for our DNS servers,
so something to keep in mind.
That's interesting.
And then finally, our load
balancers-- a lot of people
talk about load balancers
in terms of L4 versus L7.
We don't.
We talk about HTTP and
SSL load balancers, which
do what you'd imagine they do.
Internal, it's for load
balancing traffic that
would not leave our network.
So a lot of times, people
want load balancing
of internal services.
We can now do that.
And then finally,
network load balancing
is for balancing more
than just HTTP traffic.
My first auctioneer
section is done,
so now I'm going to move
on to storage, where
I'll go a little
bit deeper and talk
about why you would use one
versus the other and whatnot.
So with storage, we tend to be
thinking along three lines--
files.
I was heavily encouraged
to use the word "blob."
But as an adult human, I really
don't want to get up on a stage
and say the word "blob"
over and over again.
But I did, so they tricked me.
So [SIGH] they won.
But think of this in terms
of documents, of images,
of videos, of audio files.
They're files.
You use the word "unstructured."
They have structure.
They're just not related
to each other that much.
As opposed to databases,
where you have data
that all looks the same.
It's all telling the
same story, and it's all
supposed to be lined up
and easy to aggregate
and talk to it together.
I also liked--
I also think of this
as application data
as opposed to files,
but semantics vary.
And finally, big data,
which under the covers
is really just one
of the other two
that's gotten so big that
to get insight out of it,
you need to run the
special processes on it.
So big data is just
any one of these things
that's grown out of control.
So we'll start
with file storage.
You're storing files.
If you are used to some other
provider that calls it S3,
this is the equivalent to that.
They get a little touchy
about us and other brands,
and I'm being recorded,
so I'm nervous.
So cloud storage is
the S3 equivalent.
We have one set of
interfaces so you deal only
with cloud storage.
You create a bucket.
And the way to deal
with that bucket
is the same no matter
what type of storage
you're talking about.
So when you create
a bucket, that's it.
But we have several types--
multi regional, nearline,
and coldline.
I will describe why you'd want
to use one versus the other.
So thinking about file,
we have three areas
that we look at
it-- public content,
content that we're going to
share with the world, share
with our customers.
Process data-- we have data
that we need to run analysis on.
It doesn't need to be global.
I don't need to
share it with people.
I want it to be
close to the servers,
because I'm going to
be doing the work.
So regional is fine.
It's in the same data center,
the same data location.
And then long-term
storage is for stuff that,
at the end of the day, we
really hope we never see again--
so things like backups, and
disaster recovery-related data,
and compliance.
And people hate compliance.
Because after-- what
did you do shortly
before you pulled in a whole
bunch of compliance data?
You had a conversation
with a lawyer.
So we don't want to
touch this stuff.
We need to keep it, but we
don't ever want to touch it.
So we want it to be
as cheap as possible.
So putting that together,
we'll start at the top
and go to the bottom,
name the type.
We have public storage.
For us, it's 99.9--
three nines plus a
five availability.
Geo-redundant-- this is good
for world access content, things
like websites, streaming
video, streaming audio, gaming,
mobile.
And it's 2.6 cents per
gigabyte per month.
And this we call multi-region.
For process data, we have
a little less available.
It makes sense, because
it's not geo-redundant.
And it's accessed
by your system,
so you need to run big
data work, big data jobs.
You want this data to
only live in one place
and be pulled in
by a set of servers
in one geographic location.
We do that for you.
It is cheaper.
It's $0.02 per
gigabyte per month.
We call it regional.
Then we have two options
in long-term storage.
It's not as available.
Your time to first bite
we measure in seconds
instead of milliseconds.
But you'll still get good
throughput pulling the stuff
down.
You have to keep in us
for 30 days minimal.
Now, that doesn't mean
you have to keep it
on us for 30 days minimal.
If you want to
delete it, it's fine.
It deletes.
It's fine.
We're still going to
charge you for it.
That's the 30-day minimum.
And it's for backup and maybe
long-term, longtail multimedia.
You have a video file that's
looked at every six months.
Putting it in cold
storage and making
it public from
cold storage, it's
fine, because it's
stored really cheaply,
because it's a video
file, so it's bigger.
Storage cost is $0.01
per gigabyte per month.
But if you retrieve
it, we're going
to charge a retrieval cost
for it that goes on top
and is $0.01 per
gigabyte per month.
And our last option
is cold line,
which is just as
available, but you
have to store it for 90
days instead of 30 days.
And again, delete it, it's fine.
It's just about the charging.
And it's for disaster recovery
and for compliance data.
And it is the
cheapest storage we
have at $0.07 per
gigabyte per month.
But retrieving it
is slightly-- we're
incentivizing you to not
pull it out too often.
It's $0.05 per
gigabyte per month.
That's coldline.
So we move on to
application data,
and we move on to one of the
giant fights of our day--
SQL versus no SQL.
We could have a whole session, a
whole conference, a whole fleet
of events that just hold
conferences and sell books
and online seminars
about this topic.
So I'm not choosing a fight.
I'm saying we have
NoSQL and we have SQL.
It's fine.
We have both, and
we welcome both,
even if we have our favorites.
I like SQL.
But we have good
options on both.
So I'm going to talk
first about SQL.
We have Cloud SQL, which is
a traditional SQL Server.
It is based on our VM, so it is
vertically scalable to the size
of our VMs.
But you don't ever
actually-- there's
no-- you won't see the VM in
your list of Compute Engine
instances.
We manage the OS
entirely for you.
And we do things like
managing the backups,
and we make setting
up replication sets
and opening up network
connections pretty easy.
You'll see there
that it says types,
but there's only
MySQL as a type.
You can assume that up to this
date, we've only had one type,
and perhaps we
have another type,
and that I got told we
didn't announce it yet,
so I pulled it.
So keep your eyes peeled
for the rest of Next.
You will find
another type there.
I figured you guys are smart.
You'll figure it out.
So I figured I'd cop to it.
I can't say it, but I can't
tell you to not look for it.
Our other option
is Cloud Spanner.
Now, Cloud Spanner is
for structured data,
like traditionally what
you'd store in SQL.
We advertise it as both
highly available and strongly
consistent, which the
CAP theorem says--
if you guys are into
this sort of thing--
CAP theorem says
that's impossible.
So what we did is we
found the guy that
wrote the CAP theorem,
hired him, made him a VP.
And he came out and was
like, yeah, it's cool.
You can say that, which is--
Again, this is a
superficial session.
It's a very abbreviated
version of the way it happened.
But long story short, if you
want to dive into this topic
and why we say it's both--
if that's something you
feel strongly about, please
see me afterwards.
I'll be happy to
dig deeper into it.
But long story short says
we call it highly available
and strongly consistent.
It's globally distributed,
and it's horizontally
scalable, which is great
when Cloud SQL starts
hitting its vertical limit.
Having a horizontal piece
to this is really helpful.
Now, it's important to note
that there's a large price
differential between these two.
And the reason I say this is
because I just helped a startup
who had been fooling
around with Spanner,
not realizing that it's
a BMW, not a Volkswagen.
And so I would say if you don't
have the need for it, don't--
if it's not solving the
problem you're having--
if you're not running into
horizontal scaling problems,
and you're not--
you don't need
incredibly high latency,
make sure you read all the fine
print before you spin it up.
If you need it, it's awesome.
If you don't need it,
it's a giant bill.
It's about-- yeah.
I said I wouldn't
get into pricing,
but it's more expensive.
The last option is
Cloud Datastore.
Cloud Datastore is a
document-based NoSQL store.
It's indexable.
And you can make
it pretty giant.
We have customers that
store a lot of data in this.
We also have this thing
called Cloud Bigtable,
which if you guys follow our
papers, we have Bigtable.
We made a paper about it
but didn't release it.
And so now there's this
thing called HBase.
HBase is the open
source version of it.
And now we need our Cloud
Bigtable, which we released,
to work with it.
So it is a columnar,
low-latency database.
Not a lot of people use
it in an application.
But I leave it here, because
there are some people that
see it as a next step for them.
It's important to note that this
one also-- like Cloud Spanner,
you really need to need it.
We say that until you are
storing a terabyte of database
information,
Bigtable is not going
to be cost effective for you.
So keep that in mind.
What am I--
OK.
So I talked about files,
I talked about databases,
and now I'm going to
talk about big data.
So where do you store big
data on Google Cloud platform?
In all of these.
All of these can-- if you've got
two terabytes of data in MySQL,
it's hard to argue
that's small data.
So any one of these is
our storage for big data.
What you're really concerned
about with big data is tools.
So let's talk about
some of the tools.
Does anybody here
play with BigQuery?
A couple of people.
BigQuery is sort of--
it's magic, especially if
you're not a big data person.
You're like, how
did you do that?
You pipe in semi-structured
to structured data.
You can analyze it very quickly,
and you can use SQL to do it.
And that's its special sauce.
With most BigQuery big data
jobs, what you're going to do
is you're going to
build some sort of job
to analyze your
data, you're going
to throw as much computing
resources as you can at it,
and you get the
answer back when it's
done processing all the data.
BigQuery is different in that--
well, that whole piece of
you throw as much computing
resources as you have at it--
well, it's us throwing our
computing resources at it.
And so we keep a whole
bunch of machines
ready to go to process
BigQuery queries.
So we can usually see, for
billions of rows, performance
in under--
depending on what
you're doing, you
can get performance of a second
for multi-billion-row queries.
And in fact, I'm going
to show this off.
So let's see.
Here we are-- BigQuery.
So a friend of mine has,
in their BigQuery storage,
every Wikipedia
request ever made,
the logs for all of Wikipedia.
And so every time someone went
to Tom Hanks' Wikipedia page,
we flip a counter.
So we have those logs.
So that's a lot.
That's a lot of data.
So I'm going to go--
nope, that's the wrong one.
Formatted, unformatted.
Here's a query.
I'm going to edit
it so I can run it.
You'll see it's SQL, just like
you're mostly used to running.
And I'm going to run the query.
And it's going to come
back in one second.
And you'll see-- that's
because it was cached.
I was cheating.
So I'm going uncache
it, just so that we see.
And I'll run the query.
And it's going to
take 11 seconds.
I'm calling it.
It might take 16, but I
think it's going to take 11.
Come on.
A lot of time with me on stage.
You've been talking to
Compute Engine, haven't you?
There we go-- 17 seconds.
So in 17 seconds, we processed
just under a terabyte of data
to get this number.
This number at the bottom
is very hard to read.
I'm going to bump
it up in a second.
But first, what I'm going to do
is actually put commas in it.
Because otherwise,
I can't read it.
And I would hope
you guys-- if you
can parse that number without
commas, I'd be impressed.
Here we go.
We're going to run this query.
No, no.
That's the wrong one.
Yes, cancel.
Sorry.
There we go.
All right.
Now I'll run the query.
This will take 20 seconds, and
it will actually format it.
But long story short--
and I'll show the explanation
of all of this when it's done.
We're going to go
through another--
what was it--
0.9 terabytes of data.
And it's going to go about
20 seconds this time.
I'm going to be pessimistic.
We're not caching, because
I turned off the caching.
So there we go--
19 seconds, just
to make me wrong.
So that number,
if you can see it,
is we calculated-- we
had it up 1 trillion,
190,543,847,386
requests to Wikipedia
for two years looking
at the query there.
That's kind of awesome.
And if we look at what
it did under the covers--
I've got to shrink
down my screen--
we can actually
see an explanation.
And we can see what it
did is that it started out
with 130 billion rows of
data from all the Wikipedia
entries it has.
You see here it is.
It's all the requests of
all the tables it called.
And then it shrunk
it down to 65,000.
So it did a MapReduce on it.
And then we reduced it again
to the one answer of that.
We did all of that
in 20 seconds.
We counted up to 1
trillion processing
130 billion rows of data.
Is that OK?
Yeah?
All right.
Tough crowd.
Lunch is looming.
I know.
So big data, not storage--
PubSub, publisher
subscriber model--
basically allows
you to communicate
between multiple
pieces of our platform.
Use it a lot when
using the database
tools I'm about to talk about.
We can easily handle a
million messages per second,
meaning if you're going to do
less than a million messages
per second, you don't
really have to talk to us.
If you're doing
more than a million,
we'd just like a heads up.
So keep that in mind if
you're starting to move over
and do lots of messaging
on our platform.
Data flow-- anybody
here use Apache Beam?
No.
I saw one.
Apache Beam, but managed.
So does data
transformation for you.
You line up your workload,
transfer the data
as it goes into an
analysis system,
and you can repeat it
multiple, multiple times.
And then Dataproc, which
is Managed Spark and Hadoop
with the added benefit
of allowing auto scaling.
So it makes building
out your jobs
and throwing more resources
at it much more easy.
Important to note, just
as a side note, that
between Cloud Storage
and Cloud Pub/Sub,
you can interconnect any one
of the rest of our products.
So if you're building
an app on App Engine,
and you want to send it to
our machine learning APIs--
like, say, the Vision
API deals with images--
you can directly send
the image to the API.
But you have to
base 64 encode it,
and it's not a very
efficient process.
Or you can store
it in Cloud Storage
and then tell Cloud Vision API,
hey, I've got a file for you,
and it will handle it.
So almost any one
of these tools can
be connected to any of the
other tools through these two.
So important to keep
in mind that as you
start to solve problems, like
how do I build out systems,
this is one way to do it.
What if you need
something we don't offer?
We have non-managed
storage solutions
that you can build by hand.
Or you can go to Cloud Launcher
and get Cassandra, Reds, Mongo,
CouchDB or others.
Did not go
alphabetically this time.
I don't know what my
order of preference was.
So that is storage.
Hopefully, that gives
you a good indication
of where you're going to
find the storage you need.
We're coming in the
homestretch, and we're
going to administrations.
So administration is usually
worried about three things--
reporting, security,
and configuration.
If you've noticed, I like
to make three things slides.
You'll see that theme
throughout here.
Reporting-- Stackdriver.
Now, you'll notice
we have-- we'll
call a whole bunch of
tools we have Stackdriver,
which is weird, because
it's Google Cloud Platform.
Why is it Stackdriver?
We do that so that
you can wrap--
so it's easy to wrap
your mind around the idea
that Stackdriver is actually a
hybrid or cross-cloud solution.
So you can run it on us, and
we set it up automatically
for you.
But on AWS, most of our
products for reporting
have a one-click or a very
easy solution to get it running
and spin it up on Amazon.
And then on prem, because
all of this has an API,
you can extend--
between the API that
we have and the SDK,
you can write your own tools
that will talk to these things.
So we've got logging.
We've got monitoring.
You can build up alerts based
on things you're used to,
uptime checks, built-in
metrics, and so forth.
For security, this is important
for a lot of companies.
We now have Cloud IM.
So I'm not going to--
it could be its own
talk too, so I'm not
going dig too deep into it.
But just find Cloud IAM.
You can create
accounts that you then
can assign to roles
and permissions,
then use to lock down various
pieces of your account--
sorry, of your infrastructure.
So finally,
configuration-- you're
going to do most of
your configuration
probably command
line, probably using
the GCloud or the GSutil tool.
GCloud will do
almost everything.
But if you actually want to deal
with files on cloud storage,
you're going to want to
use GSutil, because it's--
GCloud is for management
of the systems.
GSutil is actually for reading
and writing from cloud storage.
We also have an API with
an SDK for most languages
that gives you REST endpoints
that are functionally
equivalent to GCloud.
So you can build your own
solutions in whatever language
you want and also call
them similar to GCloud.
And then finally,
Deployment Manager--
if you like writing massive
YAML files, as we all do,
you can write out your
entire environment in YAML
and then reproduce it,
either on your own project
or on new projects, with
network configurations,
with what servers
are set up with VMs,
what Kubernetes setup you have.
And this is actually how
Cloud Launcher works.
So we use it internally,
and it is available to you.
Moving on to the development.
Developers in general,
we think about coding.
We think about
reporting sometimes.
And we like using
services, because then we
don't have to write it.
So development--
we have the SDK.
Important to note that most
of the things you want to do,
you can do through GCoud.
If you're using App
Engine, you also
want to make sure
you have App Config.
Because the PMs
tell me that GCloud
can do everything that
App Config can do,
but they're lying.
Or they're wrong.
But they're lying.
Plugins-- for any ID you have,
we can plug into most of them
with tools that help
basic code intelligence
of our commands and our APIs.
And then others--
I clearly ran out
of my three-tiered icon system.
We have Cloud Source Repository.
So we have managed git that
is locked with our security
that you set up
through Cloud IAM.
And it works with one
of our other tools
that I'll talk about in a
second, Cloud Debugging.
So moving on to reporting,
we have Stackdriver Trace,
which is installed
automatically on App Engine
and on load balancers.
You can enable it through
an SDK and a couple
of other environments.
And I'll just show it,
because it's kind of cool.
If you guys have seen any of
the showcase demos, which are up
on the third floor, there's
one with a giant pi symbol
where you spin up and build pi.
You crunch 100
million digits of pi
in a very short period of time.
So that application I was
having some trouble with,
and I was looking into
what was going on.
And you see down here, I
get pretty basic information
about what's going on.
The whole request
took 92 milliseconds.
I made a call to the
identity service,
and then I went and made
a call to another API.
I can then click on that
button to show the logs
to see what was going
on at the same time.
And I can see distribution for
how long that same request took
the many different
times it was taken.
And I see-- oh, there was an
anomaly versus, oh, there's
a whole bunch that are
taking a long time.
There's a problem.
So that is trace.
It's really, really great when
you start digging into it.
So also, error reporting
for aggregating either
log data or stuff that you
sent directly to the API.
It is also really helpful
to see, is this a--
again, is this an anomalous
error, or is this something
that I now need to take care of.
Debugging-- again, if
you use cloud repos--
and this, you can actually
step debug into your code
and then go directly into your
code on Cloud Repo for stuff
running in production if you
are brave enough and bold enough
to do that.
It's available in App
Engine and Compute Engine
in a couple of
different run times.
So services-- we have
all of these services,
and not just us.
Cloud has a bunch.
We also have Ads and GSuite
and YouTube and other things.
The point I want to
get across to you
here is that most
of the time, you
need to set up some
sort of certificate
or some sort of security between
these services and your cloud
project.
However, we have this feature
called Default Credentials,
and they work on App Engine and
Compute Engine out of the box.
And it's beautiful.
Because all you have to do
is instead of setting up
a whole set of certificates,
and putting them in your code,
and storing them, and worrying
about managing that and not
accidentally adding
them to your git repo,
you can just say, give me
the default credentials
to call the service.
And that's all you have to do.
So it makes dealing with
these services a lot easier.
So it's something
to keep in mind.
I'm going to finish
with machine learning.
I am running OK on time.
And so machine learning tends
to be about three things--
using models, creating
models, or extending models.
So we have a lot of
models that you can use--
Vision API for images,
Natural Language API for text,
Speech API, Translation API.
Use them.
They're awesome.
If you want to
take the next step
and not use the model
but train models,
you want to use Cloud ML engine.
It is managed TensorFlow,
which you should be asking--
what flow?
TensorFlow is an open
source ML library
that allows you to create
portable models that you
can train in one place and
also train in other places.
The idea here is that you can
train your model with varying
levels of GPU and CPU power.
And it's OK, because you can
move them from place to place.
So when we get back to machine
learning, Cloud ML Engine--
we just changed the name, so
I apologize for bobbling it--
it's managed
TensorFlow, which does
a whole lot of self-tuning,
and it's portable.
So you can create a
model on your laptop
and move it to
Cloud ML and have it
run in Cloud ML with
much more resources
that then get self-tuned.
So that's it.
So conclusions-- so
hopefully, after all of this,
we're now putting the table
back up that we flipped over
when we saw this.
There is lots on
Google Cloud platform.
And we totally acknowledge this.
And we are working on it.
We're making this bigger.
There are 50 or so--
50-something icons up here.
I talked about 43 individual
products in this hour.
Some of it was auctioneer
call, and some of it
was designed to help you make
strategic decisions around it.
I hope at the end
of this, you now
have a better idea
of where you need
to go in order to
find the answers
and solve the problems
you want to solve.
I am around.
My Twitter handle has
been on all the slides.
So if you need to
ask me a question,
feel free to ask me a question.
You will often also
catch me out smoking,
so feel free to do that, too.
And with that, I'm going
to say thank you guys very
much for sticking
around and dealing
with the logistic problems.
And go get yourself some lunch.
[APPLAUSE]